let me tell you that guy he sits there
and plays Dumb and does all that stuff
and it's all calculated and uh he's a
good guy he knows all this stuff we talk
every day I mean you know they they get
mad at him about that we text constantly
you know every day and we send people
articles and stuff he just and that's
why I got mad at him when he was kind of
going to liberals about six years ago
and kind of playing games they were kind
of recruiting him and and I was just
like Joe knock it off
stop you know about all this and then he
got more hardcore again and he went the
right direction and then they did the
lockdowns he said screw these people
it's all true I'm going after him